All my life, I've dreamed of
getting out there into space.
Now, that was a challenge for me
because I went
to 13 different schools
and I have a condition
called dyslexia.
Today I want to talk
about three fellow black scientists,
one from the past,
one from the present
and one from the future -
all pioneers in their field.
My first hero is unfortunately
no longer with us -
his name was Alan Powell Goffe.
He was born in Kingston upon Thames
in 1920.
His father was Jamaican
and his mother was English.
Both his parents were physicians.
Like me, he was inspired
by his parents
and gained a degree in medicine
and a diploma in bacteriology.
He went on to specialise in pathology
the study of the causes and effects
of disease.
In the 1950s, measles was described
as the greatest
killer of children in history.
Goffe's work on vaccines
was revolutionary
in ending the measles epidemic.
A sample of the virus
is taken and then weakened
usually by reproducing it many times.
This creates a living but weakened
version of the original virus
which the body can fight,
stimulating long-lasting immunity.
He also worked on the polio virus
and made important contributions
to the development of a vaccine
for this too.
Tragically, he died young
in a sailing accident
aged just 46.
Dr Goffe was a true pioneer
but few people know his name
and with the important role
that vaccines are playing
in our lives today
it's wonderful to celebrate
the work of this fantastic man.
A present-day scientist
who I think you should know
is Dr Asmeret Asefaw Berhe.
She was born and grew up in Eritrea.
Sadly, when Asmeret was young,
her country was undergoing
a war of independence.
Despite this turmoil,
she was one of only 1,000 students
admitted to university in Eritrea
when she left school.
She studied soil science
and was fascinated
by ecosystems within the soil.
Her childhood experiences
led her to conduct research
into the effects of landmines
on soil,
looking at how the explosions
cause disruption
in the structure of the soil
and how they can leak toxic chemicals
into the soil.
She also worked out that
if just a quarter of the landmines
from the affected areas were removed
that this would enable the land
to produce enough food
to feed 1.6 million people
every year.
Another brilliant black pioneer.
Her work inspires me
because in my early career
I worked on the development
of a handheld landmine detector.
also trying to tackle
the same problem
but from a different angle.
Now, a scientist you should look out
for is Kayisha Payne.
Like me, Kayisha grew up in London
and showed an early aptitude
for science and maths.
It was chemistry
that most excited her.
She loved the idea of studying
the fundamental building blocks
of everything.
This passion led her to undertake
a degree in chemical engineering.
She was the first member of her
immediate family to go to university.
Kayisha was a process engineer
at AstraZeneca in Cambridge.
This is where one of the Covid-19
vaccines was developed.
Kayisha's work focused on ensuring
that drugs that were being developed
didn't degrade by the time
they were administered to patients.
Throughout her studies and her career
she was often
the only black person in the room.
Passionate about having more
diversity in STEM
Kayisha created the Black British
Professionals In STEM.
A network for black students
in the UK
to connect with their peers and
receive advice and mentoring
from black British
STEM professionals.
As she says: "When you don't see
yourself represented in an industry
it's extremely difficult to believe
there's a place for you in it."
These three black scientists
didn't only dream of a better future
but had the determination
to make it a reality.
I'm truly inspired
by these amazing people
and I'm excited by what the next
generation will achieve.